For close to two months, I played one
deck almost exclusively with the same
100 cards, but with the same cards I
participated in four out of five
brackets and had decent success in all
four. I also got to win games with half
a dozen different archetypes, tokens,
combo, even Voltron once. With that
experience, I've reached the conclusion
that if I ever quit magic and just keep
one deck, this will be the one.
Self-adapting with near infinite
replayability. So, what is it? Evelyn
the Covetous. Now, this commander is a
bit like Wick in that it's got a
distracting tribal clause, but it is
nowhere near the best vampire commander.
What Evelyn excels at is stealing, or in
her words, collecting. It's got all the
right wording. For example, the cards
are exiled with collection counters.
That means once you exile the cards, you
can use them for the rest of the game.
She also does color fixing. There are
limitations though, one spell a turn for
example, and only when Evelyn is on the
field. But do not worry, we got those
patched. The important thing here is
Evelyn is crazy efficient at
accumulating cards. Every blink gives us
four cards, one from each player, and
every clone eight. So, that's pretty
much the entire deck. We have no win
condition and everything is sponsored by
our opponents. And that's what allows us
to adjust to the brackets. Whether it's
has tribal or two card combo, we can
make it work. Brackets one, two, and
three are very doable. Brackets four and
five can be a bit challenging. My
solution to this though is going ham
with ramp. Yeah, no holding back, 23
pieces. This way, we can overwhelm with
resource advantage and as usual, our
commander will recoup the lost cards.
The game plan is simple, we ramp, keep
Evelyn alive, and blink her as much as
possible. Starting with these single use
ones. These are mostly for protection
actually, and I wouldn't use them on
their own unless I'm desperate for a new
set of cards. Also, these undying and
reanimation effects, while we're not
playing a ton of sac outlets, we can
kill Evelyn pretty easily with all these
clones. Yeah, these are super efficient
and we are packed. We are playing with
all the three mana or lower options and
they all come with different perks. Like
these reusable ones are excellent. Also,
something like devastating onslaught
which scales. Now, this is better than
cloning twice because the tokens enter
at the same time. And with this one
card, say if we pay five mana, we're
getting six triggers. That's sweet
value. And my personal favorite, Saw in
Half. Imagine using Saw in Half with one
of these undying effects. That's seven
triggers, a total of 28 cards exiled
from just that one exchange. The Mirror
Room is also perfect for this deck,
being a cheap budget clone, but also a
Panharmonicon if you have extra mana.
Oh, we also do play the actual
Panharmonicons. We're willing to pay
more, but they have to do something
pretty amazing. The Apprentice is fully,
for example, creates non-legendary
tokens twice, and these are excellent
because having multiples on the board
doubles all of our future triggers, and
it bypasses the once per turn
restriction. We get one card per Evelyn
copy, and it snowballs fast. For that,
we also have Sakashima, Spark Double,
and Quantum Misalignment. Every deck
needs a magical Christmas land dream,
and Autumn Soldier is ours. Very
expensive, very slow, but if we can just
get one myriad trigger, we are set for
the entire game, and probably the next
two games as well. Literally
generational wealth. Math quiz, I had
Evelyn and copied with Autumn Soldier.
Now, I attack and get myriad. I have
three opponents. How many cards do I
steal?
32. Seems good. Seasons of Weaving is
mostly here for making two tokens at the
same time, getting us a minimum of six
triggers. But every mode is useful, the
flexibility is excellent. For blink, the
top end are Deadeye and The Cat. These
come out to finish games, and we round
things up with arguably the best card in
the deck, Vesuvan Diplomacy. Now, this
is the one card that can potentially win
the game all by itself, and that's
pretty much the entire game plan. Again,
stupid simple. I would make a 20-second
deck tech for this, but I don't think we
have enough content to fill the
duration. Simple, 37 lands, 36 pieces of
blink and clone, extra triggers, and 23
pieces of ramp. All of the two-mana
options, we're also using all the
game-changer slots here, because mana is
really our only restriction. Worth
mentioning here is the Cursed Mirror,
being both a clone and a mana rock. It
does not get better than this. Bender's
water skin is excellent because we will
be doing a lot of things at instant
speed and being able to make a mana on
everyone's turn is so much value. Now,
even more value than that is the relic
of legends. Evelyn will die, will be
blinked, it will come in and out, it's
going to be cloned, and often times the
relic will make what, four or five mana
a turn, which is ridiculous for a three
drop mana rock. And black market
connections, now this is not a mana
rock, but it's close enough because
importantly, this gives us a vampire
token every turn. And that leaves us
with three more card slots and we're
giving those to flash enablers. Unlike
many other commanders, Evelyn's ability
says once per turn, and that's something
we can definitely take advantage of. As
for lands, it's nothing special, some
sack outlets, some protection, also ramp
and a bit of generic utility. Mana
fixing is important, but we do have
enough rocks and also Evelyn fixes mana
for opponent's cards, so we're not too
stressed here. So, a little bit about my
experience with the deck, I played games
at CEDH tables and I was actually able
to win some of them. There will be times
when an opponent is just way too fast
for us and wins before we even get to
drop Evelyn, but as long as the game is
kind of interactive and goes for a few
turns, Steve, there's a lot we can do.
Just getting a few Evelyn triggers, we
can hold a lot of interaction and we
eventually be stealing a crab or
something and take over the game.
Bracket four was actually the most
difficult because the meta is more
diverse and decks are generally less
interactive and more focused. So, we may
struggle a bit trying to assemble the
pieces and come up with a win. That was
just my personal experience across 30
games or so, I had the most amount of
success in bracket three, but for the
most part, it's pretty even. My win rate
in each bracket was around the same.
Playing this in the lower brackets is
relatively straightforward. Sure, the
deck is fast, consistent, and has game
changers, but again, there's no win
condition, so whatever the table plays,
we'll have to work with. It's
self-adjusting. Actually, I wasn't able
to find a bracket one game, but on
paper, it should be should be doable.
The only worry here is the card of
Vesuvan Diplomacy. Now, that card can
actually win games by milling people
out, and that's better than most bracket
one strategies. So, I decided to include
a single Gaia's Cradle Sanatarium to
activate once we exile everything so we
lose at the same time. That's a solid
bracket one victory, right? And I'm 100%
serious about this being potentially the
only deck I'd keep because it's
commander centric and has none of the
common drawbacks. It's adaptive and
interactive, will have plenty of answers
as long as our opponents are playing
them, and we do depend very heavily on
Evelyn, so it's important to be careful
with when we drop her and what kind of
protections we hold up. We usually don't
lose access to our commander because we
ramp really hard and we have enough ways
to recur and reuse, but still, when your
entire strategy hinges on one single
card, you can never be too careful. The
deck isn't explosive at all because,
sure, we can get our commander out early
and start blinking, getting a lot of
cards, but we are not posing a threat to
our opponents until much later in the
game. The early game is used for
accumulating the collection piles while
interacting when necessary, but once we
build up that resource, it's very
difficult to run out. And if we're able
to build a solid mana base as well, we
have late game inevitability. I'd say
this deck is quite difficult to play
because, I mean, you have to be familiar
with every strategy at your table,
balance your game between accumulating
resources and interacting, like
mentioned earlier, and eventually
finding the line among what 40-50 cards
to end the game. A budget version of the
deck is absolutely possible, but but
might struggle in higher brackets due to
the loss of the best ramp cards. Instead
of the super expensive game changers, we
switch to the ramp options that are more
oriented for the mid-to-late game, and a
budget clone like Chameleon is perfectly
serviceable. Meanwhile, lands aren't
super important. Just play whatever you
have laying around. You don't need duals
or fetches for this deck.
This way, we can cut the budget down to
$500, which is much more reasonable, and
that's the deck. Recently, I got an
affiliate link with a really cool
accessory brand. They sent me some
products to test and these look really
cool, but I've been using their stuff
way before that. So, if you're
interested, take 5 seconds, look at
their site, and if anything here
interests you, here is my code, levels,
for a discount. Thanks for watching.
I'll see you in the next video.